this video is brought to you by
skillshare
[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here to talk
about a brilliant film that captivated
fans wooed the critics and pissed off
no one just kidding i mean the
live-action film the last airbender
based on the very popular very good
nickelodeon show avatar
this film seemingly had everything going
for it great characters a compelling
story and of course
live action fire bending so why is this
film more cringe inducing than having
your blood bent
how does the guy who did this i see dead
people
royally screw up source material as
truly great as avatar
any time a movie confounds our
expectations like this we're forced to
pull out our detective's pipe and start
puffing until we either get cancer or
figure out
what the hell happened special outfit
hat and pipe these things mean anything
to you and so welcome to this wisecrack
edition on the last airbender what went
wrong and of course spoilers ahead for a
bad movie
and a good show but before we get into
it i wanna give a shout out to this
week's sponsor
skillshare when i first started writing
video scripts for youtube i was a bit
unsure of myself it was a completely new
and fun way to put my ideas into words
but i wasn't sure if it was coming
across on screen i researched other
youtubers and submitted script after
script to our content team for feedback
i really wished i had a partner or
community who knew how i was feeling
about my work
and i definitely should have looked to
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community where curious
creators come together to improve their
skills they offer
thousands of inspiring classes for
writing photography freelancing design
and more
members have the opportunity to share
their work with their class through
projects and discussion boards
i wish i had known that skillshare
offers a course literally called
going viral write film and make content
people share
where matt bellassai teaches you how to
create your own voice while balancing
relatability
don't make the same mistake i did and
check it out today
for a limited time you can use the link
in our description for a free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
now back to the show let's do a quick
recap the film like the tv show that
inspired it introduces us to sibling
saka and katara two water tribe
youngsters whose dad's off wearing
against the evil fire nation
while hunting they stumble upon a bald
kid frozen in ice
instead of running away screaming they
take him under their wing
then mike drop it turns out he's the
avatar
a messiah figure who has the ability to
bend all four elements
normie benders like katara can only do
one
lost for a century this ice kid aang is
responsible for keeping the four
kingdoms in harmony
but first he's gotta learn how to bend
all the elements katara saka and aang
set off on a journey to help the young
avatar master his powers while also
fending off the fire nation
simultaneously the very moody disgraced
fire prince zuko hatches a plan
he wants to capture aang like some sick
trophy thus restoring his reputation and
winning back his father's love
at which point he will presumably stop
sulking
now quick caveat there are a lot of
things wrong with the last airbender
for one the characters are almost
systematically stripped of their
endearing qualities
saka's sense of humor is gone and ang's
carefree sense of fun is
undetectable what's more the stakes are
never made urgent or clear enough and
aang never really struggles to beat his
opponents
and importantly aang's character arc is
murky at best
on the show he struggles quite
compellingly with guilt about the death
of his people and anxiety about the
demands of his title that culminates
invisible character growth
in the movie his arc doesn't unfold with
the same clarity and resonance there
kind of just
isn't time then there's the fact that
the show makes a point to show a rich
world with all kinds of cultures and
peoples
whether it's the influence of southeast
asia seen in the fire nation
inuit cultures in the water nation
buddhism in the airbenders or even these
florida inspired swamp people
you want me to eat old slim he's like a
member of the family
the richness of each culture depicted is
a big part of what fans loved about the
show
the movie on the other hand cast its
protagonist in such a way as to make the
central conflict look kind of like a
race war
casting aside i think this film is
actually a great lesson in one of the
central problems in any adaptation
how do you shorten a lengthy book or
television series into the runtime of a
movie and still make something enjoyable
obviously it's been done especially with
books you don't hear a lot of complaints
about jurassic
park fight club or a clockwork orange
the last airbender in a somewhat
herculean adaptation challenge had to
fit
nine-ish hours of television content
into a feature film
to stay somewhat faithful to the show
which it does in its own
very flawed way the film needs to
function like an abridged version
squeezing in the most important plot
events so that it starts and ends at
approximately the same point
luckily there's one screenwriting tool
that will let you breeze right through
all the complicated information
exposition but it's a dangerous tool at
best
in storytelling exposition is any
information that fleshes out the rules
of the world
explains a character's motivations and
so on if i kill you
that's an action if i tell you i want to
kill you because you murdered my father
that's exposition my name is inigo
montoya
you killed my father prepare to die
sometimes exposition is extremely
memorable and very iconic
i am father but more often than not
action is more fun to watch flip through
any decent book on screenwriting
and you'll find a section warning young
writers that bad exposition has
an apocalyptic effect on your career
anytime a bad piece of dialogue makes
you cringe because it sounds wooden
false and maybe a little embarrassing
for the actor it's often the result of
poorly executed exposition
you've never been stung by b have you no
no bees are genetically designed to
recognize royalty
of course proper exposition is a
necessary evil in any narrative work but
there's an
infinite number of ways to convey this
information it takes a scene-long
montage to establish that say
rocky trained a lot to get in shape it
would have taken two seconds to say
i worked out a bunch and now i'm in
shape but the universe would have been
robbed of this glory
exposition is a struggle every
screenwriter grapples with and sometimes
it can
really [ __ ] work i don't like sound
just kidding maybe more like this but uh
until that day except this justice is a
gift on my daughter's wedding day
the last airbender unfortunately has a
lot more of the
they're eating her and then they're
going to eat me
oh my god and less of the
you're a wizard harry now that we've
looked at some examples let's see how
shyamalan does
exactly what every screenwriting teacher
begs his novice students not to do
it's telling instead of showing
exposition tells us
this is things father characters actions
show us things
this boy running to embrace his father
communicates everything we need to know
without that pointless introduction
bad movies like this one chronically
tell us things instead of showing them
to us in my raid of the great library
earlier this year
i found a scroll that tells the location
of the ocean and moon spirits
but why is exposition such a narrative
kick in the nuts
according to screenwriting guru john
york the problem is really simple
most dramatic fiction demands
plausibility for characters
not to say things they wouldn't say in
real life however characters also need
to impart essential information for the
audience's benefit
that is no believable character says
hello brother to whom i lent my nintendo
switch last week wherever have you put
it
instead they probably say yo asshat
where's my switch
this though a natural and reasonable
reaction could leave the audience
confused as york explains
exposition can be awkward to present
because it rarely occurs in real life
to bring it back to the last airbender
nobody would actually say
fire nation is here instead they'd grab
the princess's hand and start running
for their freaking lives
examples like this are more rampant in
this film than covet 19 at the
university of alabama
roll tide but first a quick caveat the
show avatar
as amazing as it is is not innocent of
all
expository sins the sages tell us that
the avatar is the last airbender
he must be over a hundred years old by
now he's had a century to master the
four elements
but we would never make a video ranting
about it there are a few reasons why
first we're talking about an animated
kid show that explicitly does not
take itself very seriously
as a result its expositional statements
come off as far less wooden
it's rocking water mixed together it
means our way out
aided by its hyper-expressive animation
style the film in contrast and perhaps
out of necessity is just a lot more
serious and it can't get away with the
same childlike use of earnest exposition
after all that time searching for a
teacher i'm finally starting
earthbending
what's more the show uses slightly
didactic exposition
mostly in attempts to create a coherent
viewing experience and keep kids engaged
week after week even if they happen to
forget the whole deal with zuko and his
dad
zuko had shown shameful weakness
as punishment he was banished and sent
to capture
the avatar the movie on the other hand
regularly repeats information as if the
audience is suffering from amnesia
fire lord son in our final defense of
the show
its expository elements tend to lean
hard into emotion and motivation
the tv show brilliantly balances
exposition with emotion
information is conveyed to characters
during scenes filled with conflict their
reactions tend to render the exposition
almost invisible you're the airbender
you're the avatar
no way in contrast the film's
expositional sins come in two distinct
flavors
voice over and on-screen dialogue
voiceover is the nuclear reactor of
screenwriting exposition used with care
it can be incredibly effective and
efficient he's the man
for his time and place he fits right in
there
and that's the dude used incorrectly
it'll blow up your entire script
tyrell had told me rachel was special
no termination date
i didn't know how long we'd have
together screenwriting expert hall
ackerman warns that any time you use
such a device
voice over flashbacks you were calling
attention to it as a device and one you
had better use it effectively and two it
had better be the best way of telling
the story
if that's the case what is the purpose
of voiceover according to ackerman it
serves like a portal into the character
psyche
making us privy to their inner thoughts
which would otherwise be inaccessible
enter katara our narrator from the
get-go the movie piggybacks off the tv
show's intro which features her 45
second efficient narration that ends
with powerful emotional insight into her
character
but i believe aang can save the world
movie katara is a little less economical
let's look at a sample line the scroll
we had was proving to be helpful
aung was practicing oh wait it
it keeps going we tried to stay out of
sight but
soka became concerned we were being
followed
here katara's voiceover functions like a
shitty wikipedia plot summary like the
rest of her narration
it gives us precisely zero information
about her emotional state
according to ackermann successful
voiceover works when it shows us a
different perspective
after that you invent the spending
the abuse the fear the threat of
violence
as is the case when a character is being
dishonest with the audience or
themselves
physic took great care and reviving
indigo but qatar's voiceover doesn't
elucidate any internal struggles or
reveal anything new about herself or
even about her deep faith in aang
aung flew us to his home he told us how
he left there in a storm on oppa
here voiceover is merely a piece of duct
tape over the torn fabric of the plot
aung showed them
he was the last airbender and was
accepted to train with the master
throughout we see information conveyed
through voiceover like
my brother and i often go hunting for
food but
unfortunately my brother isn't the best
hunter in the world
rather than shown through action as it
is on the show it's not getting away
from me this time
[Music]
in the film painful information can be
conveyed through clinical narration my
mother was taken prisoner and killed
when i was young
on the show it's organic resulting from
a heated confrontation
ever since mom died i've been doing all
the work around camp while you've been
off playing
soldier what's more good voice over is
often compelling
because it's motivated a given character
has a reason for dispensing this
piece of information the most common way
to do this is through the use of a
storybook narrator as seen in just about
every disney movie
modern audiences maybe less compelled by
cinderella's plight but the device
creatively used
certainly can still work
like that's ever gonna happen
but filmmakers have gotten creative with
voiceover throughout the years for
example in the classic noir double
indemnity voiceover functions as a
recorded confession to a crime
indeed successful noir films very often
employ superb voice over that adds to
the character's complexity or reveals
their subjectivity
sometimes rendering them unreliable i
saw it once he was dead
and i was in for it who would believe he
fell out of the car
this makes it tense and dynamic the last
airbender's narration
in comparison is flat wooden and just
kind of lazy i believe the child avatar
has only knowledge of his birth element
heir but let's move on to perhaps the
greatest
sin in the last airbender the dialogue
now dialogue is frequently used as
exposition in film
but what distinguishes good expositional
dialogue from bad
according to york good exposition is
disguised by making it dramatic
by injecting conflict the greater the
conflict the less visible the exposition
as an example of successful dialogue he
cites apocalypse now which crams an
entire film's worth of exposition into
one brisk scene
did you not assassinate a government tax
collector quan tree province june 18
1968
the result as york explains the scene
manages to incorporate subtext
desire conflict and the deeply personal
to get across
almost every fact the film needs in
order to be understood
the character's evasiveness gives us
just as much exposition as the
interviewer's purely informative
questions
in contrast the last airbender tends to
rely on conflict-free exposition as when
katara blatantly
pumps her grandma for information what
is the spirit
grandma the result is boring and static
there are no
stakes to the reveal of any piece of
information i believe
that little boy might be the avatar
grandma and katara both think this kid
is the avatar and what's more
both think katara and saka need to leave
the village to help him kotara has to
convince saka but it's still pretty low
conflict
contrast this with similarly themed
encounters on the show where in katara
and grand grand disagree about whether
aang's the avatar
i told you he's the real thing grand
gran i finally found a bender to teach
me
katara try not to put all your hopes in
this boy
these tense moments are expository and
that they give background information
clearly katara has been searching and
waiting to find someone to teach her
these moments culminate in katara
choosing to go exploring with aang
largely in defiance of her grandma
although grand grand eventually gives
her blessing
all resulting in a compelling emotional
arc in contrast
film katara leaves the village with zero
emotional tension or stakes
we're going with you let's compare
another plot point
when aang finds out that the air nomads
were killed by the fire nation in both
the movie
and the show katara tries to warn aang
about what to expect when they get to
the southern air temple but on the show
after katara's worst fears are proven
right the air nomads are dead
she starts to tell him but falters aang
there's something you need to see
okay
[Music]
what is it uh just a new water bending
move i learned
katara tries to hide a painful truth
aang's temple was destroyed by
firebenders meanwhile eng's trying to
figure out what the f happened to his
home
this setup innately bakes conflict into
the reveal of this information
the helmet becomes a ticking time bomb
and when ang learns the truth we're too
wrapped up in the emotions to realize
that we are being given crucial
background information
in contrast the truth comes out pretty
seamlessly in the film with katara
eagerly volunteering all the information
aang needs
the fire nation knew the avatar would be
born into the air nomads
but our greatest grievance with last
airbender is the way it deals with
aang's central conflict whether or not
he can be slash is ready to be slash
even
wants to be the avatar in both the show
and the movie it takes some time to find
out why aang was in the ice
that is because he ran away from his
duties as the avatar however in the film
this information is revealed quite
readily and without prodding
i ran away before they trained me eng's
confession should be huge
instead it's accepted by everyone pretty
much without reaction
in contrast on the show eng tells the
truth after prodding from katara and
only to correct her misassumption
you have a right to be angry after the
monk sent you away like that
well that's not exactly what happened he
admits it slowly i was afraid
and confused i didn't know what to do
what's more he lets katara like the
audience put the pieces together herself
creating a much more dynamic though
still expository scene
you ran away the last airbender film
seems self-conscious about its
over-reliance on exposition and
sometimes the script almost tries to
repent
for example you see the writer trying to
create a compelling reason to tell us
about zuko's banishment first via his
rivalry with general zhao
as you know the fire lord has banished
his son the prince
and renounced his love of him and will
not let him return to the throne
unless he finds the avatar but the line
reveals its own redundancy
zhao literally says as you know
rendering the dialogue self-consciously
unnecessary
then the film imparts almost the exact
same information just minutes later when
zuko gets a little boy to retell the
story of his banishment
tell me what you know about the prince
the fire lord son
here there's no reason why zuko needs to
hear his own life story it's lamely
justified by the fact that he's trying
to explain to his uncle why he can't
party and meet cute girls he's been
disgraced and must regain his honor
however there's no tension to the reveal
of his backstory and it mostly amounts
to what ackerman calls
a big vomit pail of information in a
remarkably on the nose moment near the
end of the film
aang begs the dragon spirit for help
please
tell me how to beat the fire nation the
spirit replies
show them the power of water it's a
little ironic that the tension between
showing and telling comes up in the
literal dialogue of the film
if only the writer had taken the dragon
spirit's own advice and
shown rather than told us aang's story
but what do you guys think are we being
too harsh on a film
so bad its two sequels were promptly
abandoned let us know in the comments
as always big thanks to our patrons for
your support go ahead and bend that
subscribe button like it's the blood of
your enemy and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
you